All right.
Coming to the stage,
we have founder and CEO of daily dress,
me,
Nina Vere,
fashion branding,
digital media strategist,
Ishmael,
Mayhew,
celebrity fashion designer in tech innovator,
the designer of the stunning Yeley d dress.
I'm wearing Dalia McPhee
and experience design lead
for Jack Jacquard by Google,
Nina Wallia,
three d designer,
entrepreneur,
digital sculptor and cofounder of pics.
Sweet.
Yana [inaudible]
right.
Okay.
I'll go on this side.
No,
yours is on the ground.
Yeah.
Okay.
Hi everybody.
My name is a Sullivan.
I'm a software engineer here at Google and um,
I am really excited to moderate this panel of people who have been able to
bridge the gap between tech and their passion because I'm a software engineer.
I'm very passionate about coding.
Um,
but I'm also like a designer.
I'm a very artistic person and I like to think of coding and um,
all of tech in general as being a canvas because you can kind of with
programming create anything that you,
you want.
Everything that was PR that,
um,
is on youtube and everything that they've been able to accomplish is because of,
innovators and programmers.
And people who are passionate about that.
So let's get started.
Woo.
So can we first start off with everybody introducing themselves and um,
saying a little bit about their background?
You can start.
Yeah.
So my name is Ishmael.
May You?
Um,
I'm a digital media strategist.
I also do a lot of coding.
Um,
and I've always loved fashion.
Fashion is actually a very new industry for me,
but I've always secretly been involved,
um,
for a lot of reasons,
since I was a young kid.
And so this is really full circle for me as well.
I'm Nina and I'm the founder of daily dress me where we tell you what to era
based on the weather.
And this all works by using our proprietary algorithm.
And I started daily dressed me when I was in high school actually.
And now I'm 23 and working on it full time.
Um,
and yeah,
that's pretty much it.
Hi,
my name is deleon
and I'm the designer of Sierra Ramirez is a dress,
I'm not sure if you saw it.
You see it a little bit in the,
uh,
in the dark to see it light up.
I a clothing line,
uh,
mainly dresses and gowns.
I started that 18 years ago,
so I'm not going to tell you how old I was when I was a little younger and I
started with 10 dresses actually for Prom and within one year,
uh,
the line was in 1500 stores in most major department stores.
But I always had a dream to merge technology with fashion.
14 years ago actually launched the first light up jeans in the world,
took him to Macy's and Macy's said,
this is either you're going to be,
it's our biggest hit or our biggest flop.
And in one month they were Macy's biggest flop,
but I didn't give up.
Every good idea has its time and obviously today was the time.
Hi,
I'm Nina Wallia and I'm experienced design lead for Jakarta by Google.
I'll tell you a little bit about what that means more later,
but um,
Dzhokhar by Google,
what we're doing is we're making your clothes interactive.
Uh,
hopefully you guys got to see the demo.
If not,
come find me later.
Uh,
I've also done interaction design or experience design for Nike.
I did the Nike plus fuelband.
I did it for public broadcasting.
I used to work with shows like sesame street and you know,
probably all the shows you guys grew up watching.
Um,
and on the side,
I love music.
I used to be a Dj and I'm a community organizer,
so my name is [inaudible].
Um,
I have a very real long background in three d printing especially.
So I'm,
I'm,
you know,
besides designing in three d sculpting and doing art,
my art work on,
we also have a venture capital fund and we,
uh,
design technology organizations from scratch ourselves,
sorry for that.
Um,
and especially within with a real,
um,
of,
uh,
across pollinize in technology like Three d technologies,
augmented reality,
virtual reality,
uh,
sometimes fashion as well.
And trying to find some new kinds of ventures within these crossroads and a big
suite.
If everybody had some ice pops outside,
they already,
yes,
they already like it.
So that is a very good example of,
of the types of ventures that we're,
that we're busy with.
You know,
again,
you would not,
might not imagine grading a search engine meeting three d printing,
meeting food,
uh,
every day.
Um,
so if anybody has some ideas for new content ventures,
which are completely crazy,
then,
uh,
let me know.
Well,
all of you have like a really incredible careers.
Um,
I was reading all of your bio's when they sent them to me and every single one
was just like mind blowing,
but I'm sure you didn't start there.
So how has your profession changed since you first started your career?
Oh my gosh.
I mean,
for me it's changed a lot.
Uh,
well the technology,
the technology industry in general changes probably every day.
There's always new discoveries.
It's like science,
you know,
it changes and what people need changes and how people live their lives change.
So that naturally happens and there's always something different that's thrown
at you and there's a new problem to solve.
Um,
but I also think the overall makeup of how any industry,
um,
is cha has changed a lot since I've started.
Um,
you know,
we hear this buzzword of millennials a lot and millennials have really changed
the face of what corporate America looks like and how it operates.
And you know,
how,
you know,
young professionals are serving,
their audiences or the world.
So I love millennials so much too.
I will defend millennials to the death.
I love them.
Um,
well for me and my actual profession has changed a ton because when I started my
career,
I was in high school and this wasn't really a career.
It was something I was doing for fun.
Um,
it was literally something I made for myself.
Cause every morning I'd wake up,
I check the weather and then I decide what to wear.
Um,
and so over the years it grew really organically and now it is my career.
And I think it's a really interesting time to be in between retail,
commerce and tech.
I mean,
if you look around,
so many stories that I grew up with are now going bankrupt.
And you're seeing this new crop of brands that are really catering to
millennials and our preferences.
Um,
customers have more choices,
more options than ever,
right at their fingertips and the way that they're being advertised who is very
different now.
It's very native,
very organic.
And so all of this is happening and it's just really exciting to see how it
evolves.
Well,
I always say a fashion is the last frontier because I feel like every other
industry has progressed so much.
You think of cars and phones and yet like where's our fashion that should be
doing so much more,
which thank goodness we're finally getting there.
But 18 years ago in the fashion industry are fashion shoots.
I mean we were printing catalogs on paper.
The photography was being done by hassle.
Blood camera's on real old school film.
We were using,
some of our photographers know that we were using drum scans.
It was very expensive.
Now obviously everyone can do it.
Not everyone,
but I mean professional fashion shoots.
It's like,
you know,
you take the shoot and tomorrow you've got the digital images out there.
So that's a big thing.
18 years ago,
there wasn't really the volume of online shopping that there is now.
And then information,
you really had to be a fashion insider to know what was going to be big the next
season.
Now we have to keep up because you guys know before us what's,
you know,
what the next trend is.
And then I think the last thing is really being able to touch people,
touch the whole world pretty much at the,
you know,
with the,
with the touch of a button,
you come out with something and everyone's able to see it instantly.
And that's huge.
So
yeah,
to that point,
um,
my profession didn't exist when I started in my career.
Um,
so after college I went to graduate school,
um,
really super cool program,
which was basically computers as an expressive medium through doing really cool
creative stuff with the computers.
And um,
we,
this was many years ago and we,
a bunch of us got together and made this cost,
these costumes that we programmed so that the way you move could modulate sound
and music.
So you could call like Dj with your body and do a performance and were,
it was,
you know,
early days.
And so we're doing all this stuff,
but like my friends and my program,
like,
yeah,
cool,
but how are you going to get a job?
But are you going to do with that?
And I was like,
oh,
I guess you're right.
And I,
um,
at first I was like,
oh,
let me do something practical if you're right.
But then like two or three years later,
the Nintendo we came out,
the iPhone came out using the same technologies we were using to,
to do all that modulation.
I don't do you guys don't want to get an accelerometer is,
have you heard that word?
See,
everyone knows what it is now.
Nothing like it when it started,
you know,
it wasn't a thing.
Um,
so yeah,
I'm,
I'm sure like there'll be even new,
more new stuff coming up as you guys are coming up too.
Yeah,
I would,
I would answer that a little bit in a different way.
Um,
I mean,
of course I'm in my last 20 year last carry.
A lot of things have changed and know new technologies and you know,
people to express themselves in different ways and all that.
But,
um,
I would have,
uh,
you know,
advice for everybody here,
all the younger or younger crowd,
you know,
to,
to uh,
don't be entertained but be the entertainer.
So when I was at school 20 years ago,
I was the only kid at school,
you know,
how to computer on.
Of course I was fighting against the system and we had this old tools and you
know,
everybody was drawing by hand and I was told by my peers that quote,
that thing computer will kill your creativity.
And I said,
yeah,
and you're going to be so unemployed.
Uh,
so again,
to that note,
be the entertainer and to all the youtube stars here,
I'm in today's world,
it's a lot easier than when I was scoring up 20 years ago.
We didn't have youtube.
And you know,
I wish a lot more difficult to get out there.
And to your point,
we didn't have online shopping any of these things,
you know,
so,
so all of these stores are available,
so really,
really go out there and kick ass.
I agree.
Yeah.
Um,
so did he,
did you have plan for success
when you first started your career?
I'll start with you.
We've been starting on this sentence so we can start on that in this time.
If,
if I had a plan.
Yeah.
Only had one plan,
which is to find happiness.
And also everybody said all in,
in the previous panel about is a lot of talk about passion and I try to find
that inner core trying to find your passion and really stay true to that.
And if you find that it's going to be a lot easier,
you don't actually have to work,
you don't have to worry about anything because you're happy every single day
working on what do you love?
What I will say that people,
um,
it's like,
especially when I was in high school,
like I was passionate about some weird thing is or whatever,
but I still didn't know exactly where I was going.
And I think that it's a,
I want to reiterate that that's okay.
If you don't have a passion,
you don't have to force a passion on yourself.
Um,
like there are people well into their forties and fifties that don't discover
like what they wanted to do or what their passion was.
It's not something that you can just look up.
It's kind of something that,
um,
the universe presents right
self to you.
Yeah.
Sorry,
go on.
I think I'll say two things about my,
my plan.
Um,
one is,
uh,
I'm a child of immigrants.
My parents came over from another country and yeah,
they had their education,
but that doesn't always mean a whole lot when you show up and you look really
different.
Um,
and so I came up watching my parents hustle so hard and to get us to where we
are and watching that like to me there was no other choice.
It's like there is success or what else?
Cause they,
they work so hard.
I watch that,
you know.
Um,
and I was just going to carry that on.
So that's one part in the second part is,
um,
part of watching that kind of put that,
that like practicality in me,
it's like dreams,
but also I need a paycheck.
So,
uh,
what I realized is I could be in any industry through technology.
So as I was mentioning to you guys before,
like I've worked in media and TV shows,
I worked at Nike,
which is awesome because that's a sneaker head.
Like,
um,
I work in fashion now,
everything you can imagine,
every industry they need technological things.
Um,
so you can be anywhere using that knowledge.
So I think that was a major part of my plan is like,
I'm going to take this practical skill set in and be wherever.
Good.
Well,
I think because I started so young,
you know,
everyone says is saying passion,
which obviously is huge,
following a dream.
That's huge as well.
I,
I grew up riding and jumping horses and anytime I was afraid,
my trainer would always say,
throw your heart over the jump and follow it.
But I really think,
you know,
the year
my collection blew up and people always said,
well,
how'd you do it?
I had no fear because I hadn't been tainted by the world yet.
I mean,
that's the honest truth.
So I hope you guys hear this because it's your,
it's so powerful right now.
Don't let anyone tell you who you are or what you can or cannot do.
I had,
I had no fear.
I believed I could do anything.
And so nothing held me back.
I had dream and I had a passion and,
and um,
I guess that was the plan
sound,
uh,
for me.
Sorry.
That was great.
And I totally agree with it because I started young as well and a lot of people
are so surprised when they hear that.
But for me,
I don't know any different.
And I think I was almost naive in a sense.
And I didn't,
I wasn't daunted by the world either cause I hadn't really seen it.
And I'm still young now too.
Um,
so I still can be a lot more bold than people,
you know,
who have to support a family or,
have all these responsibilities.
But as far as when I was in high school and starting my career,
I guess I didn't have a specific plan for success.
I didn't think of it like that.
But what I did think about was,
you know,
what did I enjoy doing?
What was I good at and how can I combine those two things into a career?
And if I was able to,
I knew I would consider that a success.
And so I was always very creative.
I knew I wanted to do something on my own.
I was very intrigued by entrepreneurship.
And so I guess marrying all those three things is what I would have considered
to be a success at the time.
MMM.
Um,
I,
um,
have never had a plan.
Um,
I still don't have a plan.
I've always clawed my way.
I've always had a goal.
And so I've always spent my life setting milestones and,
and having a vision.
I remember Darren and John Saying,
you know,
seeing yourself
there,
you know,
no matter what circumstances you are in and you know,
some of you are already tainted by the world,
you know what I mean?
You guys are facing unimaginable,
you know,
trials and circumstances.
You know,
I did when I was this age and I was raised by my grandmother and there was never
really a plan for my life,
um,
because the plan wasn't to be raised by my grandmother.
So,
um,
I've always set milestones and I've always clawed my way to where I want it to
be and always set a vision for where I wanted,
how I wanted to see my life.
And that always changed to two because you know,
you,
you get inspired by new things and I don't want anyone in this room to feel
married to,
um,
any industry or even any vision to yourself.
Just know what you want.
I love what you said.
You just want it to be happy.
Um,
I think that's one of the most important goals anybody could ever ask for is
just to choose to be happy.
Um,
and,
and be good to people and be good to yourself and,
you know,
think of ways that you can give,
use your gifts and your talents to give back to the world.
So,
yeah.
Yes.
That was beautiful.
Yeah.
One thing that,
that one word that you used,
milestone.
That's one of my favorite words.
Um,
because like goals and dreams and stuff can sometimes be arbitrary,
but I feel like when you have milestones,
it doesn't feel like it's the end.
It's almost like a stepping stone.
Sometimes people view goals as like,
that's the end now.
I got here,
now what?
But I do.
Yeah.
So I like that,
but I think you did have a plan to get to each milestone,
right?
Kind of.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
I mean I,
I just figured things out.
Yeah.
You've got there though.
Yeah,
I did.
I heard I was listening to a podcast and I heard something that said a goal
without a plan is just a wish.
And I was like,
oh,
read me.
Yeah.
So,
um,
the next thing,
we only have like,
what,
15 minutes left?
Um,
I'm going to go over because the last person went over,
so I'm sorry.
Um,
so if you had to pick,
okay.
Okay.
If you had to pick one thing,
what has been a major highlight of your career thus far?
Yeah.
Um,
the measure,
the major highlight of my career.
Um,
I guess isn't anything career.
Just anytime I hear someone telling me that whatever I've done in my career and
my business has positively impacted them and motivated them to get up in their
darkest moments,
you know,
I think that is a highlight for me.
Cool.
Um,
whenever I get emails from my users who tell me about how a daily dressed me has
made their lives better and streamline their morning routines,
it's always really touching.
And I love receiving those.
Okay.
Well,
I'm Canadian and I was honored by the Consul General of Canada a few years ago
and that was a big deal for me.
It felt very proud,
felt like I was representing my country.
That's awesome.
Always have two part answers.
One,
my,
my highlight is always the latest thing that I did.
So right now it's,
um,
our jacket with Levi's.
So you can go get this right now in any Levi's store.
Well,
mostly by stores and it's interactive,
so it's pretty cool.
And then,
um,
kind of similar to what you were saying of I got to work with Michelle Obama's
office on a digital campaign to help kids be more active.
And I mean that always feels super good.
Yeah.
I would say the proudest thing for me would be the next thing that I haven't
done yet.
You know,
so I don't really,
unlike reminiscing of the past,
I haven't,
I didn't write a book.
I probably should have all this kind of things.
I didn't write a memoir.
No,
I just want to make the next thing that he's the craziest,
weirdest shit that I could ever imagine.
So,
um,
I don't yet know what it is,
but that's the next thing.
Yeah.
So I'm gonna to piggy backing off of that,
I'm going to ask,
well,
a one last question,
we'll go to the audience,
but if we don't have time to have everyone answer,
if just maybe two people want to interject.
Um,
what is a tech related path that you have not gone down yet but are interested
in exploring?
We kind of want to know what do you guys want to go?
Like what's a cool thing to kind of go into next that any of you might be
excited about?
Cause I know he's been talking about,
what is it?
Tell me where he's trying to discover it.
Oh,
sorry.
I did,
um,
public service.
I um,
yeah,
I mean my generation,
we need to step up.
It doesn't have to be all the same people we've been seeing like as an,
uh,
members of Congress as the people representing you and your city.
So,
um,
yeah,
something I'm not tech related.
I want to do one more.
Woo.
I'm still thinking there's somebody else.
Anyone else?
And then we'll go into the audience.
I think just,
um,
just to pick up piggyback off of what she just said.
Also social issues.
I'd love to see some technological and innovations and mobilizing communities
and,
you know,
really,
um,
not just mobilizing communities politically,
but also inspiring,
um,
people of several different backgrounds and multicultural backgrounds and
origins to really be active and powerful in their communities and use that
technology to grow that and make the world a better place.
Awesome.
Yeah.
So we'll go,
let's give our panel a round of applause.
Yay.
Okay.
How many questions do we have time for?
We have time for one question.
Who's going to ask our panel?
One question.
Okay.
How did you find your passion?
How did you find it?
I think everyone should answer that.
Uh,
my fashion,
my passion found me.
Um,
I think like,
you know,
there comes a point in life if we're all being realistic where you hit rock
bottom,
you know,
um,
like Darren said earlier,
like what you put on Instagram as your best moment,
right?
But there's a lot of other moments that are very discouraging where you want to
give up on yourself.
And so the magic happens when you apply grit.
Um,
and you can't have magic without grades.
So don't get discouraged by the grit and the mundane moments
and the unglamorous moments.
You know,
where your throat is sore and you don't want to keep working and you don't,
you're tired.
Um,
use those moments to motivate you to make magic.
[inaudible]
one thing I would say is to not be so quick to define your passion because it's
often not something like fashion or you know,
tech.
It might be some,
uh,
feeling like accomplishing goals or solving problems,
things like that.
And so don't look to,
you know,
put a box around it and just really look out for things that you intrinsically
enjoy and things that you're also very good at.
That's good.
Yeah.
I think I always say that if you can't stop thinking about it and your desire to
do it is greater than your fear of failure,
then you know,
you've hit something.
So,
and that's changed for me over the years,
but technically speaking,
it's always been about creating something.
Yeah.
I think for me it was like someone mentioned before,
like a little bit of like,
what I don't like to do.
So,
uh,
I started college as a computer science major and I was like sitting there
coding and I was like,
one day I was like,
I don't want to do this for all my life.
I want to be a music journalist.
And so was like,
that's after two years of coding.
So I went like to journalism school but I couldn't like I already knew how to,
how to code.
I already knew how to make things interactive.
So then I was like running around like let's make this multimedia video.
And they're like,
go bother the drama kids and like let's make an interactive play for theater.
And it's all because I already knew how to code stuff.
But it was just finding that like,
oh,
I can do more than just stare at a screen.
I can make this coat,
do cool stuff.
And I think that's where it came from.
What's the kind of kind of to your point of sale?
I mean I didn't have to work for it.
It found me,
but also I had pretty much finds me every one.
Not Anymore.
Every single night,
I would wake up in the middle of the night with an idea,
you know,
so kind of you have a higher power controlling you,
so you kind of makes you kind of let go and just joy,
enjoy the ride.
I mean there's nothing that we have to find for you in a way,
but,
but I can also imagine that a lot of people,
it might not come naturally.
So I have one word for that,
which is curiosity,
stay curious and try to find the weirdest,
you know,
meet the weird people,
go to the park and look at the grass and you know,
go to the library and read the weird book,
you know,
all this kind of things that you,
you might find inspiration in areas where you might never imagine it to happen
to you and,
and,
and ask questions and meet a lot of people and also,
uh,
meet a lot of old people.
Ask them about their experiences through,
through life.
Yep.
I want to
thank all of you for coming out.
I know coming
to any part of La is really difficult.
So,
especially over here.
Um,
and I'm sorry that it's so cold,
but,
um,
yeah,
thank you all for being here.
Are you going to be around to talk afterward or,
yeah.
Awesome.
Okay.
Um,
can we have one more round of applause for our panelists please?